and a fruit you also be here me on your
helmet radio now I know y'all got love
questions there ain't no point in trying
to talk because he ain't got no love
y'all just stop stasis so you don't
likely remember there's only a hard pill
to swallow else bails shepherds
welcome to the future
I'm not sure why zuzela wants a holdup
we gotta get you off this ship door I'll
talk you through names Earl by the way
what
I am rod autonomous door hey hi red
security clearance required for entry
that uniform is really more of a dusty
rose
to shoot the doll your red laser will do
the trick fine read access confirmed why
do I even bother being thorough
read access confirmed the aberration has
escaped Shepherd's investigate 00
Methuselah sound to us we best hurry
read access granted engaging and tremor
that security lasers are blocking the
widely estate colors y'all need to get
the bridge set them off
watch out the Shepherd's got their heads
gonna be happy to see go
hostility
read access granted
looks like that flash doors are stuck
half open y'all gonna have to go under I
am rod the autonomous Dorne I welcome
that to Matt's blog in the way folk I'm
detecting a transcriber Noah roundabouts
though little jump dear noggin should
help this is stimulate your synaptic
today
use your back and grab to suck off that
too
oh no not susie
aberration detected Shepherd's convert
that may Christ crystalline energy will
help your noggin make connections with
an ailment systems that didn't I'm alone
and head back to the escape pods I don't
open for little flying heads access
granted squad deploy two ships knock off
innocent
opening c hall take it easy in there it
can get a bit hairy
opening d hole
now shove them sooners on returns
opening d hall all right domain to the
same cards tapping it all for this [ __ ]
discharge
and there had to see see if y'all can
find another way into that escape pod
best about Lee many tracks listen at the
center of this mess is Methuselah some
sort of man's computer made a long time
ago it controls just about everything
y'all might be wondering where all the
people over was very much of us left
some time ago folks had their minds
moved on over to robotic imposter bodies
or left the world a pretty hard place to
live in and impostors were a way to live
forever might just be the last
flesh-and-blood person left in the
galaxy being some other folks are
working to get rid of Methuselah try to
restore humanity to what it once was I
don't know we all are y'all got here I'm
Jacqueline all the city's little long to
y'all but I'm thinking we can work
together figure it out Oh looks like
this potholing riding on a secure landed
Nick let me see if I could divert it
again through it's me Earl your noggin
still intact we got to get y'all off for
this space station before the shippers
get older
there's a pleasure court y'all can meet
a lot of citizens don't take it personal
they see like the gods Cruz Methuselah
spur chip called the Omega gem into
everyone's nugget an ordinary little
thing stops folks from feeling much for
thinking
let me see if I get your mini scan
online there she is
watch yourself the two boys are grown
full of lasers your helm has been
designed to extract energy from all
types of things don't use your vacuum
drive to open up that Casey and get out
the good stuff inside
the lights are so i can see time y'all
can head land into citizens to but don't
worry their minds get auto loaded into a
new body of anything goes sideways
take the time in the signal
I need y'all get to the satellite relay
and help me clear up this mess of a
signal y'all should be able to fix the
signal thing
dieter
Oh
access granted
I can maddie autonomous nap a nap you
can see you're lost would you like help
becoming not lost need to go somewhere
in particular Mackey to help you have
arrived at the pleasure point which you
like to know more map you can see that
you are different mapi does it mine
is that the new Yuri's model I am rod
red clearance required for entry access
granted or that you're too Liam begins
access granted
access granted I'm on Oh jewelry don't
tell me you're a Taurus
y'all film it rains app station galvin
use these to travel between other
mid-range zappers plus y'all find them
access granted enjoy
you there my little dog is missing I
need help finding him you can't miss him
he has a very distinctive collar
eternity access granted the tranquility
of the stores is yours citizen Walton
says it smells each lasers again
disengaging
nice
she's just opening
right seems to be the same
I know he's lost his collar again
access granted access granted
in illegal weapon fire since all
hostility
opening electrosex access only access
granted
lucknow name chef coats thank you mated
there should be some around the house
y'all can head land into and clear the
lockdown working order sir
look down or have a nice day
access granted
Hex's y'all made it to the satellite
relay any jolt realign five satellite
dishes to clear up the buzz so I can
help y'all off this station I marked the
satellite control terminals on your mini
scale
I am rod orange security required relax
access denied orangey is sad access
granted access granted
you
there's enough to Colombia
well look at see their hollow
crystalline bouncy y'all can use that to
reflect lasers while you're flying your
noggin around but each time a laser hits
your shield it drains a bit of power
access granted
engaging intruder
separate at once
damage received
you
there's no not citizen read access
granted there's one at seven this
control stations it has been damaged
that's 14 more to go unusual activity
detected in the satellite chalet it once
damage received and engaged
it has been damaged